وعليكم السلام
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
سوره المزمل 73
الله سبحانه وتعالى
السماء منفطر به
كان وعده مفعولا
السماء
منفطر
قيل المعنى السماء ذات انفطار
وذلك من ثقل ما سيكون
من الامر والاهوال ليوم القيامه
وجاء بالتذكير
مع ان السماء مؤنث
وذلك لاسباب
يقول بعض العلماء السماء يجوز فيها
التذكير والتانيث
وقيل
لانه بمعنى السقف
والضمائر تابعه للمع معاني لا للالفاظ
وقيل مبالغه
في حال انفطارها
يوم القيامه
guide
kindel
‏falling
you have some
this is
absolute rule
many exceptions a rule and that is
that things that have opposites
are usually referred to in theeminine
in Arabic everything is male and female
اعتماد
العمده في ذلك السمع ما سمع عن العرب
صلى الله عليه
‏principl and one of them is things
pairs on the body
things have opposites us are in
theemine. ‏So for instance
a person has a pair of hands, a pair of
eyes, a pair of ears,
right? A pair of eyes pair of hands.
This is referred to the feminine. قال
اليد بالتانيث
اللفظ مذكر لكن المعنى مؤنث كذلك الرجل
كذلك العين
اللفظ مذكر
لكن المعنى مؤنث
كذلك ما فيه التقابل مثل السماء والارض
متقابلتان
فيكون فيهما التانيث السماء بالتانيث
الارض بالتانيث مع ان اللفظ مذكر
[Silence]
take isine
tak place
السماء inite might
meaning on the day of judgment or
metaphorically that way
كما يقول تعالى ثقلت في السماوات والارض
الله سبحانه وتعالى
كان وعده
مفعولا
[Silence]
فيرب فعل فعل ماضي صح
لكن فعل ماضي ناسخ يقال له ناسخ يدخل على
المبتدا والخبر
فيكون المبتدا
اسمه والخبر فعله صح ولا لا؟ كان واخواتها
والقصه في المدرسه كان واخواتها وان
واخواتها هذه تسمى نواسخ لانها تدخل على
المبتدا والخبر وتنسخ هذا المعنى
‏verb
now what can mean eng
us it me
as it implies a pse
but we see it used in the qu
in something has nothing to do with time
in this ver right here
if we were to understand this verb
‏to be
prom used to bean
not
only us to be
many
can the ver is
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ان الله كان
عليما حكيما سميعا بصيرا
كان هنا يقول العلماء
كان هنا ليس على بابها
هذه ليست على بابها من المعنى
المعنى للتوكيد
يعني كان لزياده التاكيد في المبنى وفي
المعنى
فقوله هنا كان وعده مفعولا
هذا اشد من قوله ان وعده مفعول هذا اشد
كان وعده مفعولا كانه في الماضي وانتهى
ولا يمكن تغييره كما انه لا يمكن تغيير
والعبث بالماضي
‏timeulate
why
because if something is
can we change it can ever be changed no
so just as something can never be
changed when it's in the past sometimes
emphas is placed on statements to
articulate that this
‏sure so
[Silence]
وجفت الصحف انتهى الامر انقضى لا يمكن
وقال صلى الله عليه وسلم حتى يعود اللبن
في الضلع
يعود اللبن في الضلع مستحيل
and the point here is emphasis
Allah's command
is so certain it might as well already
happen
is so that we can speak about
and that's why you findes of the day of
judg spoken about in
‏how we a man was before and said this
to him and said this to this to many
cories
what
did the day of judg happen have people
been judged have people been resurrected
of not thean
‏to
certa
this is so
that you might as well go ahad and speak
about the t
i was going to do something i hav done
it i'm going to do something and you
approach me to try to get me to stop to
not do it and i say it's done.
الله سبحانه وتالى
كان وعده
مفعولا
‏more
of speaking aboutudg
uses areom
is as
unchanged
as certain as the has already happen
and of those promes ‏is the day of
judgement. Correct but also of those
promises is giving victory to the
believers. Also of those promises
is defending the believers. Also of
those promises is rewarding the good
doers. Also of those promises is
punishing those who need to be brought
to justice. Also of his promes is
paradise and of his promes is
retribution. Correct. ‏are all his
day of judg is one of those promes so
the word here
his prom is more than just the day of
judgly
this statement is made in the context of
the day of judg corre
he speaks about the day of judg says
meaning the day of judg exceptionally
falls into this but theing
‏might happ
الله سبحانه وتالى
ان هذه
تذكره
فمن شاء
اتخذ الى ربه
سبي
سبيلا
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ان هذه
ان هذه يعني هذه الايات
هذه الايات التي ننزلها عليك
ايها الرسول تترى متواتره متتابعه انما هي
تذكره
فمن شاء اتخذ الى ربه بهذه الايات سبيلا
‏One of those possibilities is these
verses
these verses which we are sending down
upon you messenger prophet of ours
these verses
they are
ainder.
‏andes
to
use of this in order to
in to cut toى
which places this b in the of techny
doesn't it it's not technology in the
sense that it's electronic
‏Techny is a tool that you use to do
something that youally cann do on your
own
or something that will make it easier
for you to do. This book is our
techology to reach Allah.
‏How can human being find to
الله سبحانه وى any
gu
impossible
and this is why all innovation is reed
out the gates
because what is innovation
innovation is a path
[Silence]
‏are
anger Allah
‏If a person innovates,
meaning worships Allah on his terms not
on Allah's terms, then this person is
claiming that they can
get by without the map. They don't need
the technology. This is good to have,
but I don't really need it. I could have
gotten anyways on my own because I'm
really clever.
يا اخواني واخواتي في الله
[Silence]
سبحانه وتالى
‏B
exer
take
how gu
without
no how
bases the second sent on the first
he uses
ف
فمن شاء
الفاء تدل على ماذا؟ نكرر هذا كثيرا تدل
على
ترتيب ما بعدها على ما قبلها
وتدل على السببيه وتدل على الترتيب
هذه ثلاثه صح ولا لا؟
الفات دائما تدل على ثلاثه اشياء اشياء
اولا ترتيب ما بعدها
على ما قبلها
فمن شاء اتخذ الى ربه سبيلا
هذا مبني على ايش؟ ان هذه تذكره
اذا لا يمكن للانسان ان يتوصل الى الذكر
دون هذه الايات
ولا يمكنه ان يتخذ الى ربه سبيلا دون هذه
التذكره هذا اول معنى المعنى الثاني تدل
على ايش؟ على نوع من السبب دائما تحمل
معنى السبب
تحمل معنى السبب
يعني بما ان هذه تذكره
بها وبسبب هذه التذكره
اتخذ العبد الى ربه سبيلا
وتدل على العطف والفوريه
تدل على العطف والفوريه
[Silence]
Hence
is used exactly
‏and be reward by
the sent here come to the hence be
reward by the wordence me the reward is
and based upon what comes before it
which is coming to
‏andulates
the meaning ofusealityanuse
here
‏Hence
whoever wishes to take a path to his
lord may then do so hence
meaning the only way a person can take a
path to his lord is by way of the
technology of this b there is no other
gu to
in any other now is it this
‏books people
what about
what about in they have guidance yes
theyve been with and furthermore they
have been abgated
which means that anything
of the previous books
that is relevant to this and us is
already in the quران
وكيف تكفرون وانتم تتلى عليكم ايات الله و
فيكم رسوله
من يطع الرسول فقد اطاع الله
وما ينطق عن الهوى ان هو الا وح
رعمر
بن الخطاب
الامام احمد
يقول رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم والذي
نفسي بيده
لو كان موسى فيكم حيا ما وسعه الا ان
يتبعني
الله اكبر ويقول
والذي نفس والذي نفس محمد بيده
لو كان فيكم موسى حيا فاتبعتموه
وتركتموني
لضللتم
صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏would have otherv
said another
[Silence]
موسى ابن عمران
عليه الصلاه والسلام
اسرائيل
[Silence]
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى الله عليه وسلم
انا نصيبكم من الرسل وانتم نصيبي من الامم
‏He said I am what is I am your por of
messenger and you all are my na we were
me for each other a hand
and so our messenger محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم is take
and understandingران
صلى الله عليه وسلم
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا
نساله سبحانه وتعالى
ان يبارك لنا في جمعنا هذا نساله سبحانه
وتعالى بمني وكرمي وجود ان لا يترك لنا
ذنبا الا غفره وان يترك منا مدينا الا
سدنا ولا يترك منا مهموما الا فرج همه ولا
مغموما الا فرج عنه غمه ونساله سبحانه
وتعالى ان يسلل سخيمه قلوبنا وان يطهرها
من ادران الالحاد والشبهات والشهوات
ونساله سبحانه وتعالى ان يجعل قران ربيع
قلوبنا ونور صدورنا وجلاء احزاننا وذهاب
همومنا وان يعلمنا منه ما جهلنا وان
يذكرنا منه ما نسينا وان يعلمنا الحكمه
منه والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا
محمد